If you clicked on this video, then let's just
get this out of the way up front: there are
major spoilers ahead for the most recent episode
of Game of Thrones.
Last warning before things turn into a spoiler-filled
free-for-all.
Entitled "The Bells," the latest Game of Thrones
episode saw Daenerys Targaryen and her allied
forces carry out their siege of King's Landing.
It all came off the back of Dany witnessing
Cersei Lannister executing her friend Missandei,
and Daenerys herself executing Varys after
he betrayed her.
Clearly, Daenerys wasn't in the calmest or
most rational state of mind when she and her
troops rocked up to the Westerosi capital.
Watching Missandei be decapitated, quickly
realizing that people in Westeros love Jon
Snow and will support his legitimate claim
to the Iron Throne, and understanding that
she only knows fear in the country proved
too much for Daenerys.
She unleashed fire and fury on King's Landing,
commanding her dragon to burn the city down
even after its people rang the bells and surrendered.
But it wasn't just dragon fire that blazed
through King's Landing.
Bursts of emerald flames erupted throughout
the city, too.
For those who may not recall, that's Wildfire,
a highly flammable and incredibly volatile
liquid created by the pyromancers of the ancient
society known as the Alchemists' Guild.
Wildfire begins as a bright green liquid and
burns with great strength when it's ignited.
It doesn't carry quite the same properties
as normal fire, as it cannot be extinguished
with water, only with sand.
Season 8, episode 5 wasn't the first time
viewers caught a glimpse of Wildfire, of course.
Cersei utilizes a huge cache of Wildfire hidden
beneath the Sept of Baelor to blow up the
place of worship during season 6, which kills
then-Queen Margaery Tyrell.
That allows Cersei to claim the Iron Throne
after her son, King Tommen Baratheon takes
his own life following the fiery carnage.
Wildfire appears in season 2 as well, when
Tyrion Lannister learns that Cersei is planning
to use Wildfire as a weapon of defense against
Stannis Baratheon and his fleet on Blackwater
Bay.
Tyrion and Bronn pay a visit to the Head of
the Alchemists' Guild in King's Landing, just
ahead of the Battle of the Blackwater.
The alchemist tells Tyrion and Bronn that
Wildfire might be potent enough to burn off
people's appendages and then highlights an
intense connection between Wildfire and House
Targaryen.
"After the dragons died, Wildfire was the
key to the Targaryen power."
Wildfire was discussed again during season
3.
On the fifth episode of that season, Jaime
Lannister reveals the true reason he slaughtered
the Mad King Aerys: the tyrant wanted to burn
every last inch of King's Landing using Wildfire.
The Mad King, realizing that his opponents
were going to win the battle, had his pyromancers
tuck stores of Wildfire in various locations
throughout King's Landing.
Jaime explains to Brienne of Tarth that the
Mad King was obsessed with the stuff, and
he loved watching his enemies burn.
"He burnt lords he didn't like, he burnt Hands
who disobeyed him, he burnt anyone who was
against him."
As past seasons have established, Wildfire
is a chosen weapon of House Targaryen, one
that its members favored when its greatest
advantage over the Seven Kingdoms, their dragons,
all died out.
It only makes sense that Wildfire would appear
again when Daenerys, the last living child
of the Mad King, let the devastation of death,
the reality of fear, and the overwhelming
desire for power turn her into a version of
her father.
The Mad King attempted to burn King's Landing
with Wildfire and couldn't, but his daughter
finished the job decades later.
It's almost guaranteed that the Wildfire seen
on season 8, episode 5 came from the stores
that the Mad King's pyromancers placed across
King's Landing, ones no one had found until
Dany ordered Drogon to blast his flames everywhere.
It also draws yet another terrifying parallel
between Daenerys and her father, the man she
tried so hard not to become up to this point.
Will she suffer the same fate he did, killed
by a knight with a swift hand?
The final episode of Game of Thrones will
reveal the answer.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Game
of Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.